ROGER MARTINEZ:
Today we're talking
about VM Manager, Bare Metal
Solutions, and CloudSQL
Insights.
I'm Roger Martinez, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We've just announced VM Manager,
a suite of infrastructure
management tools designed
to simplify and automate
the maintenance of large
fleets of Compute Engine VMs.
This Cloud native solution has
Google scale infrastructure
in mind, providing
a simplified toolset
for automated compliance
reporting and software
deployment at scale.
Check out the blog
to learn more.
Google is committed to being
a leader in open cloud.
Part of that commitment
is Bare Metal Solution,
which enables developers
to run Oracle database
workloads on Google Cloud.
And now we're announcing three
enhancements-- availability
in our 10th region, Montreal;
a new, smaller 8-core server;
and support for
PCI, DSS, and HIPAA.
To learn more and see it in
action, head over to the blog.
CloudSQL Insights is
a simple open tool
that helps developers quickly
understand and resolve
database performance
issues on CloudSQL,
allowing your database
analysts to focus
on more strategic tasks.
Even more helpful, we've made
insights for the previous seven
days available to everyone
at no additional cost.
Those metrics will be
displayed in the dashboard,
so check them out for yourself.
We've just announced
the general availability
of Dialogflow CX, part of
Google Cloud's contact center AI
solution, which includes a
brand-new set of capabilities
for advanced virtual agents.
With this virtual
agent technology,
your contact center agents
can focus on the highest
priority customer interactions
while your virtual agents
hold down the fort
handling routine calls.
Check it out today.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.